this is me sprinkling a secret
ingredient babe I'm gonna take you into
my secret kitchen on some dumplings I'm
making for my roommates that ingredient
is a mess but I'm not gonna tell them
that because I know a lot of folks are
still afraid of MSG which is short for
monosodium glutamate it's a savory
satisfying seasoning that's in a lot of
things you probably eat every day by
chips can't soup in KFC but for some
reason when it's used in East Asian
cuisine especially Chinese food people
freaked out there was even a condition
named after it Chinese restaurant
syndrome some symptoms supposedly
included applications at a cafe and
others went so far as to say
irreversible brain damage but study
after study has shown msg isn't the
cause of any of these symptoms the FDA
the EU and the UN all say it's safe to
eat and we certainly don't hear about
1.4 billion people in China experiencing
any side effects so why do so many
people think msg is a dangerous
ingredient and while it's Chinese food
targeted the late Anthony Bourdain had
one theory
racism I decided to investigate by
eating cooking and breathing msg for a
few days hi I'm Yara and I absolutely
love Chinese food I eat a lot but it
never experienced the so-called Chinese
restaurant syndrome ever so I went to
New York
to meet a Chinese American chef who
isn't shy about publicly using MSG and
he has a rad Brooklyn accent hi I'm Kris
Kris is known for his dumpling and uses
msg specifically in his stir fries
so we poured some rye msg out on the
table cool and I tasted this one kind
and then this MSG filled chicken powder
if you want diners where they have soup
they're not boiling bones for eight
hours they're using this but you don't
come out of the air saying I have a
headache this stuff is so damn tasty but
why monosodium glutamate is one part
sodium and one part glutamic acid when
it dissolves in your mouth the two
separate and once that glutamic acid is
free it causes a flavor explosion on
your tongue and brings out a unique high
or savory meaty taste that consume your
whole mouth that taste is called umami
aside from sweet sour salty and bitter
it's the fifth flavor the human tongue
consents and it was discovered by
Japanese scientist who basically
extracted msg from seaweed in 1908 and
that Amami flavor bomb that free
unshackled glutamic acid is also
naturally found in things like tomatoes
mushrooms and Parmesan cheese but MSG in
its powdered form that's basically pure
unadulterated umami chefs these days
love adding a mommy to their food which
is what we did and then we sprinkled on
one final source of bhavani msg it's as
a finisher you wanted just a little bit
and usual spam when I was in China
though they were a little bit more
generally I was always a little bit
little cheap with absolutely nothing
happened no headaches no palpitations no
nausea if you go to China and you go to
the supermarkets in China you're gonna
see aisles of msg like you would see
care for cereal we're talking about msg
this little bit of great
their tones - it gives him the older
crowd come over any they'll be right to
your face it'll be like you don't cook
with that image t stuff do you I know
you from China but you're an American
house you got to do things the way we
like it but how did MSG come to get such
a bad rap I wanted to know is there
actually any definitive science that
links MSG to those negative symptoms
we've read about and dr. Ken Lee is
gonna help us get to the bottom of that
science er please call me Ken all right
ken is a food scientist with a passion
for msg in New York's Chinatown is his
old stomping ground now used to be my
uncle's - meat market it's now a
Pokeball
did your parents cook with MSG
absolutely it's just like salt and
pepper miss G's an essential ingredient
of Chinese cooking
is there any like double-blind a
scientific study that proves any of the
health symptoms I can say absolutely not
in a scientific study where people don't
know what they're eating they're fed msg
or a placebo sugar pill I'm sure people
on the sugar pill develop symptoms as
well could even be psychosomatic a
little bit of chemistry here glutamic
acid is a component of protein okay hey
you and I are both made out of protein
yeah already in you yes in you to
everyone that's watching this video so
how did the stigma against MSG come
about in 1968 a Chinese American doctor
wrote a letter to a major scientific
journal he claimed that whenever he ate
at Chinese restaurants in the US he
experienced none us all over his body
general weakness and heart palpitations
his letter was titled Chinese restaurant
syndrome he suggested it could be caused
by a number of things including MSG
readers then wrote in talking about
their own symptoms and scientists
started studying it - but a lot of the
initial research was faulty
scientists messed up by assuming MSG was
already the culprit using ridiculously
high doses of it and failing to use
placebos properly but it was one study
in 1969 that caused a massive panic if
famously injected MSG under the skin of
mice leading them to develop brain
lesions no human would actually consume
msg that way no but actually a good
point if you just took common table salt
and inject it under your skin you could
induce a real toxic state right solid
scientific research came out debunking
msg myths in the next few decades but it
was too late no MSG signs had already
popped up around the country everybody
hears the accusation and no
he Tunes in when they hear the verdict
of not guilty so that's what happened
with MSG it's amazing just one letter a
bunch of flawed science and an entire
cuisine an entire people stigmatized but
here's the thing there's a huge double
standard we actually eat lots of non
Chinese foods with MSG but you don't
hear about people getting sick from them
we're gonna go pick up some foods and
snacks that have MSG in them very openly
good idea all of these have MSG in them
however when it's in B's it doesn't seem
to generate a controversy you won't find
a label on any of these products we you
know MSG free because MSG is accepted as
a generally recognized as safe substance
by the Food Drug Administration okay hey
Murray
I'm not having any reaction is there
like a small percentage of people that
had reaction yeah absolutely what's more
likely they're reacting to other
ingredients that are in that wonton soup
or whatever they attributed the MSG to
why do we distrust foods like msg
because it's used extensively by Asians
it's just ignorance
so if MSG is in all these Western foods
why do people freak out when it's in
Chinese cuisine
it met up with Sarah Lee Sarah wrote a
book about the eight flavors that make
American cuisine and MSG is one of them
we met up with her at the Museum of food
and drink which has an exhibit on
Chinese food and MSG MSG is too savory
as like a sour patch kit is too sour
it's like the most pure form of savory
this is the bowl of MSG right yes sure
try it nothing happened but first we had
to order some Chinese takeout so they're
explaining Chinese restaurant syndrome
like that's Dina phobic you're
essentially blaming an immigrant culture
for making people sick a lot of racism
against other cultures revolves around
this idea that like you're not even
human look at what you're eating it's
full of this poison msg but how did MSG
get to the US in the first place
after it was discovered in Japan MSG
made its way to China became super
popular and Chinese immigrants then
brought it
with them across the Pacific but one of
the main ways MSG actually entered
America was through canned food by the
1930s the US had become one of the
largest buyers of MSG in the world and
the seasoning eventually found its way
into military rations condiments TV
dinners you name it the major consumers
of MSG in this country are Chinese
restaurants it's American processed food
every brand from Kraft a Kentucky Fried
Chicken and I've never heard someone say
that they have burrito syndrome that is
not happening Americans like to blame
immigrants for things when Italian
immigrants first came here they were
villainized for their use of garlic and
garlic was I know it's laughable right
now what American doesn't cook with
garlic the smell the flavor was really
symbolic of not wanting to become
American four five six generations later
we love Italian food so could MSG one
day be as widely accepted as garlic
perhaps but there's a long way to go the
stigma is still very much here which is
why a lot of chefs are still hesitant to
use it at their restaurants and that's
why we're here to talk to chef Lynn hi
she runs a modern Vietnamese restaurant
Lynn and her family are from Vietnam but
their ethnic Chinese and came to the US
as refugees
my parents cooked with MSG so I'm very
familiar with the ingredient but as a
professional chef growing up in the
industry because of the stigma there was
a lot of pressure not to use the msg
Lynn is afraid that she'll lose
clientele if she starts using msg in her
restaurant but she still finds other
ways to add umami to her food add a
little bit of fish stock mommy in there
now and the stigma against msg has even
touched Lin's family her dad still uses
it but her mom doesn't cook with it
anymore so we went to Lynn's house to
cook with her parents
you cook together with your wife you
don't use msg in cooking today no
somebody said nobody's good disagreement
between mom and dad then we cook two
dishes one with msg
to see which one tastes better
[Music]
yeah this one definitely has I think a
little more fuller feel to it kind of
coat your mouth it really brings out the
other flavors that are in there I can't
imagine it's like food from my culture
if I had to tell everyone like oh I've
had to remove an ingredient from it you
know I feel like that would just be
really sad day for me the experiment we
did at Lynn's house of course brings me
back to the experiment I started the
video with secretly feeding MSG to my
roommates PSA do not secretly put stuff
in other people's food it's a bad idea
do not do this at home I basically put
one teaspoon of this into the filling
one teaspoon in the entire dumpling
filling flavor how do you feel after
eating MSG perfectly fine satiated
satisfied my roommates love the taste
and didn't get sick and of course they
didn't because well the science says MSG
is perfectly safe what I learned by
making this video is that people are
afraid of MSG for a number of reasons
there's the initial flawed research
there's the rumor mongering or racist
but things are looking up a new
generation of Asian American chefs are
taking back the narrative so I hope the
next time you order some Chinese takeout
and someone starts talking about getting
a headache or something else you'll be
able to tell them it's not the wonton
soup and it's not the MSG it's probably
just in your head
I hope I've convinced you guys there's
nothing to fear about MSG that doesn't
mean you should just go about dumping
tons of it all over your food just like
salt or really anything in life consume
it in moderation
anyway share this video with friends and
family who think they get headaches from
MSG and see how they react